a bunch of illegal aliens descended on
Chuck Schumer's home last night
chanting if Chuck won't let us dream we
won't let him sleep here it is so first
thing no one's stopping you from
dreaming this is the trouble with
euphemisms right you know but also those
people look like they're 30
I thought the dreamers were these cute
little six-year-olds who didn't do
anything wrong and they're really nice
those are just adults those are adults
who haven't figured out their own legal
status and their own immigration
situation Jacob why don't we just round
these people up and deport them they're
clearly in violation of the law they're
boasting about being in violation of the
law they're rubbing our faces in it look
to keeping chuck schumer up at night is
almost enough for me to offer them full
amnesty then on a larger point it's so
disrespectful of american law of the
american government of a country that
has been so good to these people given
them free education handouts health care
what why don't we just round up all of
the rabble-rousing ones and send them
back to whatever godforsaken country
they fled from in the first place this
is the question of the hour and I think
that you know the fact that they
protested Chuck Schumer who's been
probably their biggest advocate in the
Senate maybe with a couple of exceptions
but he wasn't even home that night so
obviously that group protesting at his
house weren't the best and brightest of
dreamers but I think that so I think
that we should look at it in stages just
to round everyone up they'll just come
right back I think first off we got to
get the border secured and then we can
say okay is this person worth giving a
citizenship is it as a citizenship test
or is this person a criminal deviant
that we should send back either way it's
going to be a struggle as far as policy
goes especially as as long as the media
keep giving them headlines you know
these children that's right the 30 or 40
year old children and on that best and
brightest point the data that we have
what the mainstream eating would have
you believe is it's all six year olds
with seven degrees from MIT we're really
grateful and love their country and
they're just the most all-around apple
pie people in the world but the data we
have is that 25 percent of them are
illiterate half of them don't speak
English in the demonstrations like these
we see deep ingratitude and entitlement
from a country that's been very good to
them
Benji if Schumer won't give Trump the
wall and an end to chain migration will
we just let daca expire and start
shipping these people home who is gonna
blink first well I think I'll answer
that question a different way I think
that conservatives need to embrace the
dreamers who are here and doing good
things now there are people who are here
doing bad things but that can be said
about any any population the fact of the
matter is is that a lot of these
dreamers had no control over whether or
not they got here and they're just
trying to live their lives in peace and
I and I don't think that protesting
group kind of showcases what the entire
population is like so that being said
there is a population like the people
who are protesting Chuck Schumer which I
think that you made a really interesting
point talking about how Chuck Schumer is
kind of the biggest advocate of these
folks and you know when when black lives
matter or the dreamers protests
basically everyone an alienate everyone
that's not gonna get anything beneficial
done and it's fairly frustrating and it
makes their case look a lot weaker and I
think that that's unfortunate because
there are a lot of good dreamers here
who didn't have a choice to come here
and should you know should be given the
opportunity to succeed and be successful
and it's not their fault that they're
here so I think that conservatives need
to differentiate and this is something
that Republican congressman the
congresswoman said the other day was
that you have to differentiate between
the dreamers who could be very good
people who had no intention of coming
here whatsoever and are just trying to
live their lives and the illegal aliens
who are crossing the border I think if
there's an important distinction there
and it's you shouldn't want them in not
though I worry that it's a distinction
without a difference because they use
this term they use the most loaded term
imaginable dreamer what on earth does
that what does dreaming have to do with
the essence of this issue which is
illegal aliens resident illegal people
what what does that have to do this they
seem to be ossified in time as Victor
Davis Hanson wrote eloquently a couple
days ago so we're talking about a group
of people from only this period to this
period who were brought over below the
age of eighteen now some of these people
are almost 40 years old as I had
mentioned earlier half of them don't
speak English a quarter of them are
illiterate Oh does the category of the
dreamer as the Democrats called I will
not use that terminology because it's
such a deceptive insidious euphemism but
of these this category of people the
daka people the Democrats admitted this
in a memorandum two weeks ago that
they're relying on these people for
their electoral strategy because they
know that if they're granted amnesty
they will trend overwhelmingly to vote
for Democrats
so should Republicans embrace a group of
people who don't share a lot of as a
category don't hold together very
coherent lis and who you know don't
appear to have any advantages over other
immigrant groups or other immigrant
groups from Latin America who have come
here illegally and who are gonna
legalize a million new Democrat voters I
just don't see what the advantages for
the Republican Party to say yes we need
to grant amnesty to them even the vast
majority of the country doesn't want to
give them amnesty and 56 percent of
Democrats don't even want to give them
amnesty
I think this is a total a total game
being played by Democrats they're trying
to fool us and I wouldn't do it at all
I'm more than happy to keep people in
the country who are who will benefit the
country and who really are little
children I really don't have any means
to support themselves but some 40 year
old who's out there screaming at Chuck
Schumer because we haven't given him
enough absolutely not send those people
back especially and this is the most
important thing if they're going to vote
for Democrats if the so called if the
Dok of people will agree to vote for
Republicans for 25 consecutive elections
give them blanket amnesty I'm all-in I
think we've reached a grand compromise
I may though I think the Republicans
just just speaking as a conservative
have really dropped the ball on outreach
to latina families because they have
this fake perception by the fake news
media that oh the Republican Party is
the party of old white men but that's
not true anymore but Republicans have
been very bad at sending out that
messaging because really if you talk to
Latin American families they have a lot
of values like they are pro-life they
are pro marriage they they are
hardworking people who have good worth
work ethics and they would and they can
and will benefit society so I think that
if the dreamers are daca or daca
recipients as you call them if they were
to change and switch sides and say hey
we're not going to vote for Democrats
we're gonna vote for Republicans and
we're going to show you how we can be a
benefit to American society I think that
I think that they could see a turnaround
as far as as far as that goes but I
think that Republicans need to be better
at messaging to that particular
community sure they work hard and go to
church so hopefully it won't be hard to
get them to agree to vote for
Republicans for 25 consecutive elections
Benji did you have a final point on this
yeah first of all I don't know if it's
even a political issue and I don't
really care if they vote Democrat or
Republican to me it's a human issue to
me it's not political at all all it
takes is the affairs of men politics as
Aristotle defines it it's how men
interact with one another in cities to
me I care more about these people's
lives than I care about who they vote
for but I think it's up to Republicans
to reach these people through our
ideologies that can click with their
personalities and I think that that's
incredibly key and I think it's an
important point that was just made that
Republicans need to do a better job of
reaching out to these folks and not
making the differentiation between
dreamers and illegal aliens and also
lumping all the people who you know all
the dreamers into the category of the
protesters outside Chuck Schumer's house
I also just don't think that that's fair
so I think that there's a few key
distinctions to be made there sure
they're all illegal aliens that that is
that there's no distinction between a
dreamer and an illegal
Elian but you're right some of the
illegal aliens are wonderful people who
are patriotic and like America and work
hard and go to church and we should keep
those people especially if they vote
Republican and some people are awful in
their gangsters and they commit crime
and they're a net drag on the population
and they won't assimilate and they won't
learn to read English and they won't
learn to speak English and to lump those
people in with the good patriotic people
who came here through no choice of their
own and who have who love their country
and are dedicated to it that we
shouldn't lump those two people together
I absolutely agree